because you think a lot of parents would
you know encourage their their
children's kind of high aspirations yes
like you told your mom you when I was a
kid before I want to be a comedian my
dream was to be the president of the
United States it's the only real job I
ever wanted okay only time I wanted an
office I wanted to be the president
United States I told my mother she's
like you better not do get shot no no
and I never tried to be good in school
at all be President the Whooper was the
point and the Hillary Obama's mother did
not say that she had a different message
as a comic obviously likes the George
Bush is like a gift to worldwide so
what's it like now he's the gift that
keeps giving no he's got something to do
with this oil spill not the president
but he's watched when we really get
under all of this we're gonna find JB
initials on a cuff link down working the
rig tonight all the red lights are gone
out I don't understand can you do jokes
about Obama
it's weird cuz he's just so damn cool he
can't tell jokes cuz he's black no no no
he's just too cool it's like doing jokes
about Brad Pitt what can you say about
your wife is hot it's very hard if you
were attractive you know that you guys
don't have to worry
[Applause]
I have friends I'm not gonna name names
goldie hawn i take it you know then you
know and just say would you believe i
have a grown-up daughter and you're
gonna go yes
it's very hard for a woman to get older
yeah and older men because I always
faked orgasm and now these old guys you
know you're moan and groan in the wrong
ear they don't hear it
[Applause]
Melissa my daughter are you single
yeah we'll talk with the king of America
I he owns divid oh you know the porn
Awards the red they have a red carpet
I'm not lying to you on the porn Awards
a red it's shaved but it's a record
full of hosts yeah because mr. crystal
okay
nine times you've hosted the offer I've
been accused of that
[Applause]
I read where as you travel the world
kind of that's what you recognize even
more than the movies you've been in a
lot of times yeah they'll call me Oscar
the actual call stand like this because
you you've done it once once yeah but
can you enjoy it was the whole evening
just been to oh my god yeah you know the
worst thing about I know if you found
this when I went for my first production
meeting they said great Hugh were very
excited and they they gave me a one
sheet page to talk about the show it had
sigma-1 Hugh Jackman opening 7/8 minutes
question mark
commercial break one segment Tilghman
like okay can we just stop there for
second what do I do in this 7m I said
don't worry it's up to you and I was
like okay I'm not you know I'm not Billy
Crystal right that's why not sort of
sorted out that first seven eight
minutes then I kind of enjoyed it and
it's it's daunting when you walk out and
you see this is a great audience but
imagine that it's all gigantic movie
stars with big heads okay all head
everyone's got huge but I was at you are
on the couch with kind of nerd central
no no Tina you've told about but you you
do a lot of material about growing up a
nerd but you really weren't yeah no I
really was we've got photographic
evidence there you go this will prove it
haircut was done by folding my face in
half
the guy from spinal tap ooh did it my
mom used to take me to a haircutting
school because you could get like it's
good literally a two dollar haircut and
the guinea pig and the sign outside the
school said London Paris Upper Darby
you've talked about your late blossoming
your sort of sexual awakening thank you
for bringing that up I was wanting to
make sure everyone knew I was a late
starter and yeah for sure I don't I
probably didn't see a penis until I was
at least 20 and that was probably a
medical journal so a healthy penis
[Laughter]
but then but you this is so weird to be
talking to some of you did do that the
physic feat quite early again thank you
yeah no I think is you mr. ed was in
body fat yeah yeah I did I was you know
wearing that haircut and like a bra I'm
everything my mom taking me to JCPenney
and and trying a bra on over my clothes
in the it's like this note there's no
turning back literally at the same time
like 1980 the same time the Kurt was
scaring men the streets of st. Louis now
smash cut to
talking about Latin and the genie of it
you must be like animators must just
love working even in that phone what did
you do 56 voices as Aladdin yes it was
fun to do voices that you'd never hear
in a cartoon like Jack Nicholson the
idea of him being in a cartoon is like
maybe a little wrong for the kiddies it
was fun because the first day we did it
they just I said can you mind if I try
something and they went Oh fine and then
by the end they had 23 hours of material
to choose from but and even the great
thing about was to even make fun of
Disney's own marketing stuff like the
idea of them selling everything and that
was the first time they even made fun of
themselves which was kind of great did
you feel like Disney were interfering or
they just let you go oh they let me go
because after a while I realized it
certainly works with and then after that
it was like this kind of tradition of
hiring comedians to be in in cartoons
which is great because they come in
there riff like crazy and the great
thing is when I see you give them a
voice and then they draw and then the
animators go from what you gave them and
go even further which is wonderful and
can you look at a cartoon ik over the
voice well like with Happy Feet I got to
be like I played two different
characters initially three but then
there were that the one voice sounded
too familiar but when I got to play an
Argentinian penguin machismo penguin you
know the guy's Argentinian guy so going
what do you do know you want it looking
at you know you want it look at it don't
be afraid of the flippers and I brought
you some pebbles that's some bling baby
you want some bling you know you do
yes your heart and you know I got a beak
that'll make you feel so goo and then
you had like all the crazy ones you know
like penguins there was a story this
week you see it about a penguin in a
Wildlife Centre in Torquay right it's a
little penguin right it was rejected by
its mother right it's very sad aye well
done oh look at you mother so what do
you do with a lonely little baby penguin
you buy it a friend now I can't help
feel longer in the shop yeah
[Music]
that's my friend he doesn't do anything
he's been dead for two years nobody made
me is it did work it really worked the
little baby penguin was doing really
really well till it choked to death and
a big Google I remember the part when
they actually got Norwegian I think the
Norwegian ornithologist found out that
about gay penguins and they had two
gaping wounds who lived in the New York
zoo and they were cohabitating for years
and they've just by the fact that they
just kept bringing each other bling like
I made this for you really gay penguins
yeah they gave really gay
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you